يعود لدوري الابطال بعد غياب العشرين عاما
قضيه يوفنتوس تشغل الوسط الرياضي الايطالي
واخيرا اسعف الاسبانيه تتحدث عن واقعه
فينيسيوس هذه الاخبار هو غيرها نقدمها لكم
من العربيه رياضه اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
حجز يوكاس المقعده رسميا في دوري ابطال
اوروبا وسيشارك للمره الاولى منذ عشرين
عاما الصحافه في انجلترا تحدثت عن هذا
الانجاز كمالقه الضوء على التعاقدات
المميزه والمدروسه للفريق خاصه وان هدف
النادي في البدايه لم يكن احتلال احد
المراكز الاربعه الاولى وهذا بحاسه بمدربه
ايديهاو من جهتها تغنت جماهير الفريق بهذا
التاهل واحتفلت في شوارع المدينه حتى
ساعات متاخره من الليل
في ليله مشؤومه للسيده العجوز سقط افريقيا
رباعيه امام امبولي وخلال نصف ساعه شاهدت
جماهير يوفنتوس فريقها يهوي من المركز
الثاني الى السابع بعد خصم عشر نقاط من
رصيده جماهير البيان كونيليا بعد هذا
القرار خاصه وانه جاء قبل عشر دقائق فقط
من انطلاق المباراه من جانبه دعا اليغري
مدرب اليوفي الجهه المختصه بالبد في الامر
مره واحده وتفادي التلاعب بمشاعر اللاعبين
والمشجعين
وصل فينيسيوس جونيور نجم ريال مدريد
التعليق على حادثه الهتافه العنصريه ضد
عبر حسابات على مختلف مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وعلى موقع تويتر غرد بنقائلا
بانها ليست المره الاولى التي يتعرض فيها
للعنصريه او لرسائل الكراهيه
وبعد ان تجاهلت الموضوع يوم الاثنين تحدثت
الصحفي الاسبانيه اليوم الثلاثاء ان وقعت
فينيسيوس جونيور وجونير بالنسيا صحيفه
ماركا عن ونس وقالت لا يكفي ان لا تكون
عنصريا بل يجب ان تكون ضد العنصريه صحيفه
اس كتبت على صدر صفحتها الاولى العالم مع
فينيسيوس وعرفقت العنوان بصوره للنجم
البرازيلي ورئيس ريال مدريد فلورنتينو
بيراس
[موسيقى]